[Música]
quem de vocês já ouviu dizer que mulher
é o sexo frágil e quem de vocês já ouviu
dizer que um homem nas pedreiras pra mim
ninguém disse
desde pequena
a gente vem trabalhando na nossa casa
assuntos de reparo de reparar uma casa
pequena uma mãe separada do marido com
sete filhos eu sou a quinta ea gente
tinha uma vida bem difícil mas a gente
era muito feliz unido e uma das coisas
que nos unia são as obras as obras nos
uniram tanto que até hoje fazem parte da
minha vida em especial porque a minha
mãe sempre nos ensinou a se preparar
assim empoderada a desenvolver a
desenvolver as nossas próprias
habilidades e assim eu fui crescendo
eu fui bolsista de uma escola particular
e lá eu via muitas muitas questões
muitos problemas de relações entre as
pessoas vibrando discutindo o negro e
via as relações de pobre rico vi mulher
o homem as discussões e não entendia
muito bem isso e isso foi fazendo
trabalhar a minha vida interna
mesmo quando aqui nessa mesma foto vocês
estão vendo aqui a gente fazendo uma
calçada uma calçada de de basalto
irregular
essa calçada é bem pesado até hoje a
época hoje em dia tudo formado retinha
retilíneo é cortado e aquela época muito
difícil tem um traço da parede como é
que vai fazer o quê que massa que vai
preparar e foi assim que chegando à
maturidade
eu fui chefe de família como a minha mãe
eu tive duas meninas gêmeas a betina ea
bruna e
ali eu comecei a me fortalecer enquanto
mulher
antes disso eu tinha trabalhado com moda
e eventos eu tive muitas oportunidades e
de graças a deus por nós e branca porque
houve um país muito muito preconceituoso
em todo sentido então de novo volta quem
tem grana quem não tem comida o que está
acontecendo no país rico muito triste e
ao mesmo tempo tão alegre tão cheio de
perspectivas
isso me magoava muito sitran dou em toda
a minha história isso foi aflorada
quando eu fui mãe e mãe de gêmeas e
chefe de família e ouvir as
oportunidades que eu tinha e via as
oportunidades às mulheres que não tinham
mulheres muitas vezes sozinha na maioria
das vezes as chefes de família que não
tinha emprego que nem tem formação como
é que essa pessoa vai trabalhar se não
tem creche
se não tem respaldo se a sociedade não
ajuda se não tem política pública para
essa mulher como é que é esse andar essa
preocupação fez que eu terminasse no
serviço público onde fiquei durante oito
anos mais ou menos
e eu saí dali muito chateada porque eu
não vi o acompanhamento eu não vi
projetos impotência ao que a que
tivessem sustentabilidade a gente
entrava no serviço público enviar alguém
trabalhando um processo interessante vai
mudar o governo mudava tudo de novo nada
andava eu sempre lembrava da minha mãe a
minha mãe foi uma figura muito presente
porque ela se virava ela ela entendia
que a gente precisava de uma casa melhor
de uma vida melhor e que só as nossas
escolhas e que fariam a gente tem isso e
ea uma vida melhor e as casas como
tantos problemas e houve a situação do
desemprego porque que eu não poderia
aprender melhor eu já tinha feito tanta
coisa errada na obra mas ao mesmo tempo
fui aprendendo foi estimulando
trabalhava em outras etapas mas não
achava que a profissão tem coisa de
homem e tem coisa de mulher
isso não existe então o que eu fui
pensando como é que eu vou montar um
projeto saindo do serviço público ou
tantos eventos e mais maduras minhas
filhas de morar na alemanha eu
vocês sabem de uma coisa eu vou encarar
vou pegar esse projeto vou deixar alguma
coisa para o mundo vou começar até
porque naquela época isso era 2006
em 2006 o cenário brasileiro era outro
tinha muitas obras as pessoas de fora
vindo de outros estados morriam de frio
aqui na obra e eu pensava porque essas
mesmas estão dentro da obra e por que os
reparos que a gente precisa
os reparos da nossa casa não dá conta
perder que não faz serviço bem feito que
pega o dinheiro em bolsa vai embora quem
de nós não tem uma história que não seja
legal nesse ponto então por que não
ensinar as mulheres
e não é que eu fui lá apresentei a ideia
de uma loja de material de construção e
não é que deu certo
nós conseguimos 25 vagas para 25
mulheres
apesar das pessoas acharem que era uma
ideia muito maluca que eu era doido
enfim isso não era coisa de mulher que
era coisa de homem mais de 300 mulheres
foram se inscrever e elas vinham de
carroça que a pé de bicicleta
atravessava a cidade pra ir lá se
inscrever para fazer um curso de pintura
predial e aí a gente começou a entender
que ó as mulheres querem mesmo começou
um processo a gente fez o que a gente
vai fazer primeiro vamos fazer numa no
um link lugar
aí começamos num asilo pintamos vazio
deixando o asilo bonitinho e foi daí que
a gente começou a entender mulheres
começaram a entrar no mercado começaram
a pintar as casas eu chegava para fazer
o monitoramento das casas o que
acontecia as mulheres às vezes os donos
da casa tinham saído de casa
a mulher estava em casa pintando
arrumando a sua casa a casa da patroa
enfim da dona da casa ea mulher deixava
as crianças e sair para o banco fazer as
atividades
e isso acontecia se nós tivéssemos
pedreiros alguém estranho a gente sabe
que não toda vez tem que marcar a fôrma
e lá com mulheres era diferente chegava
às muitas vezes ela está fazendo almoço
juntas pintando nasce ea uma outra
realidade uma realidade que eu gostaria
de ter tido pra mim então eu vi aqui a
satisfação das mulheres em receber e dos
próprios homens porque as mulheres
entrando dentro da casa elas vão lá e se
organize
são elas deixam tudo tapadinho bonitinho
né não tem perigo tem uma outra
concepção que a mulher já vem com aquela
história de cuidados de casa e ela levou
isso naturalmente para a obra até nós
crescemos e e e isso teve todo um andar
colocar no mercado de trabalho
metodologia como é que a gente foi
construindo a mulher começava a se
tornar uma cidadã ea primeira coisa que
ela fazia naquela época em que ela faz
até hoje 1º dinheirinho que ela pega é
levar pra casa e levar pra casa passa no
supermercado vai tratá família isso não
sensibilizou muito porque não tem aquela
história do rap hour na segunda feira
estou de volta no trabalho né sexta
feira pega o dinheiro vou pra casa leva
de comida pra casa segunda-feira todo de
novo no trabalho olha o comprometimento
a atuação e eu nunca entendi muito bem
isso porque as mulheres na realidade
elas fazem parte do processo da
sociedade ea gente precisa sim entender
que as mulheres precisam ter melhor
tratadas se não houver políticas
públicas para as mulheres o que vai ser
feito qual é a realidade que nós estamos
construindo para esse país se a maioria
das mulheres são chefes de família a
maioria da da série de famílias são
mulheres ou seja a forma como a gente
trabalhando está errada a violência que
nós estamos acontecendo que nós estamos
vendo dia a dia e ela passa por que os
mesmos têm profissão ea construção civil
faz parte disso sim porque não tem coisa
tão pesada
a gente pode fazer o trabalho dos homens
fazem a gente não vai ter o trabalho
deles e eles fazem a parte deles ea
gente faz a nossa a nossa de acabamento
e sensacional
a gente tá cada vez estou aguentando
mais nisso então com isso aquele projeto
começou em 2006 ele teve visão a gente
formou ceramistas foi enganar o pedreira
o sexo frágil olha aí ó começou a
construir foi fazendo ali a carta teria
de formar gente foi aprendendo a
construir paredes e aí nós tivemos
professores maravilhosos que o mesmo
digo só falta botar saia porque a
sensibilidade deles com as mulheres
trabalhando na metodologia
dentro daquela andré god que trabalha
aquela questão das dificuldades que a
mulher vem e o conhecimento que ela tem
ea gente muito aprendi com elas
resiliência é o que as mulheres mais têm
e elas com dinheiro não tem problema ela
saiu de casa tranquilamente sem ter que
voltar e enfrentar a situação do da
violência então não adianta falar em
pagamento se tu não tem conhecimento e
se tu não tem educação a educação faz
parte do nosso dia a dia é o primeiro
lugar que a gente deveria dá atenção
porque a partir do conhecimento ea forma
de conhecimento é diferente não é chegar
lá e dá aula teórica a mulher não queria
isso e entender o processo da obra eu
vou dizer pra vocês que muitos homens
nos procuram também pra fazer curso com
a gente
muita gente tem muito dinheiro pedindo
porque não adianta ele chega na obra ele
é que ganha tudo é o mesmo obra que bota
ele no bolso porque não tenha prática da
obra então manusear das ferramentas
utilização nos em poderá se nos em
poderá estar lado a lado com o homem
sempre o homem está tão feliz assim
fazendo esse trabalho que disse que ele
precisa ser pedreiro e nem todas as
mulheres querem também então para isso
tem que construir um sinal de cidadania
a gente tem que botar advogada ela tende
a começar a aprender no museu que é
gratuito
ela tem que começar a participar dos
processos do dia a dia da gente e ser
feliz em conjunto com o homem ea mulher
e cada um com a sua escolha
então foi ainda a gente vai trabalhando
feliz a alegria das mulheres eu
empoderada eu faço um outro trabalho o
meu trabalho depende da minha e do meu
conhecimento
então a gente foi em dólar as paredes
chegamos em a em 2003 assim e nem contei
para vocês
em 2006 passou 2007 e 2008 eu não tinha
mais dinheiro vai continuar o projeto
e aí eu fui fazer a única coisa que eu
podia vender o único patrimônio que eu
tinha que era uma casa porque eu apostei
no negócio eu queria que a coisa mas o
mundo tinha que mudar pra mim eu queria
ver essas mulheres melhores porque eu
acreditava
e era um sonho ser seguido que agora não
é mais pensou em uma equipe maravilhosa
que tenha por trás está trabalhando hoje
eu só levo pra frente à ideia e estou
aqui preocupado em passar para vocês a
melhor maneira possível vocês
compreenderem que nós mulheres
precisamos estar empoderadas e
principalmente através da educação
mas nós chegamos então vende a minha
casa e foi seguinte e foi quando estava
dura dura dura não tinha mais grana pra
nada eu fui indicado para um prêmio e
nível nacional e internacional
e aí quem me viu foi a humanidade
fundation na suíça e eu virei a favela
um da humanidade fundation que trabalha
a questão das líderes né como na
realidade fui selecionada como como uma
líder a ser multiplicado o processo de
trabalho e em 2013 eu cheguei junto com
lanús vila flores que é um prédio foi
construído em 1920 aqui em porto alegre
que é um projeto muito bacana também que
é trabalhar o reparo
ali a gente reparou que as mulheres
faziam diferente toda a ambientação que
elas ganhavam muitas vezes nos a gente
ficou muito feliz de ver que os lanches
que elas recife repartiam ali muitos uma
parte ia para casa porque ela para os
filhos
a gente ficava feliz de ver que elas têm
essa comunhão mas ao mesmo tempo a
preocupação de que essa mulher é enfim
ali nós vimos que várias mulheres
começaram a chegar até nós aí vieram
engenheiras médicas enfermeiras
jornalistas
todas começaram a construir um processo
de mudança do prédio e aí vieram negras
índias todas as cores raças transexuais
tudo participar conosco numa verdadeira
comunhão de reparo e aí a gente foi
vendo a alegria que até a transformação
que isso podia podia sentir nossa vida
então pensa assim que é uma obrigação
para nós é uma obrigação do ser humano
levar adiante uma ideia que faça a
mudança do nosso mundo hoje é necessário
que a gente comece com uma pequena
mudança e ela está na parte mais frágil
que nós temos de mais forte que há na
família
não cito tem uma mãe poderá dá como eu
tive a minha é o momento da gente se
juntar porque anular que começa no largo
é que começa a despertar essa
consciência como a minha mãe fez e faz
essa consciência de crescimento de
escolha para onde é que eu quero isso
se houver essa consciência humano vai
começar a mudar a minha mãe hoje tem 93
anos
aliás vai fazer daqui a pouquinho daqui
uns dias ela faz 93 anos e o ano passado
ainda estava comandando uma uma uma obra
na casa dela e pagamos todo o telhado e
quem estava junto os filhos os netos e
os bisnetos e quem fez o acabamento
final foi a personal pedreira dela que
cada vez se juntam mais são mulheres
ocupando espaços são mulheres vindo para
atender um outro mercado que está muito
assistido então quanto mais trabalho a
gente vê que a gente não dá conta hoje
isso está fazendo com que a nossa função
cresça e se unam foi ao a palavra que eu
mais ouvi lá no começo era maluca tudo
não isso não é coisa pra mostrar pra
mulher hoje é a palavra que nós mais
ovinos
esses são os outros estados pedindo os
outros pelos outros está ali nós fazendo
massa tudo trabalhando no reparo como é
feito às nossas professoras
nós tivemos um grande crescimento ea
gente
na realidade hoje a gente coloca muito
de todo o coração o nosso trabalho para
que a gente continue fazendo cada vez
melhor
então como a minha mãe fez e faz
fortaleçam as mulheres fortaleçam porque
é delas que a gente pode fazer com que
uma nova sociedade se construa no brasil
e no mundo então por uma sociedade
melhor por nós construído por todos nós
homens e mulheres na mesma luta pra
gente continuar e deixar o mundo muito
mais bonita muito obrigado
[Aplausos]